when they meet in Brussels on December 9
European Finance ministers will try to
reach an agreement on the so-called
parent subsidiaries directive its
purpose is to prevent companies from
suffering from double taxation on the
single Market though it is sometimes
abused by companies to avoid paying
taxes in any member State hence the need
for new Provisions to prevent tax
avoidance the commission and the eiib
will brief ministers on the outcome of a
task force on investment which has been
working to build a pipeline of projects
to boost EU competitiveness and growth
ministers will also discuss the
commission's 3155 billion Euro
investment plan to Kickstart the
European economy over the next 3 years
ministers will also discuss the alert
mechanism report that initiates the
fourth annual round of the macroeconomic
imbalance procedure this identifies
member states that may be affected by
imbalances that hamper their growth and
for which further reviews should be
undertaken the annual growth survey
which is adopted at the same time as
this report takes stock of the economic
and social situation in the EU and sets
out broad policy priorities for the EU
as a whole for the coming
years finally ministers will have an
exchange of views after the presentation
of the annual report of the court of
Auditors on the implementation of the EU
budget for the financial Year